[Music]
so my name was my 41st birthday and this
helium inflated stormtrooper showed up
at my door and I couldn't possibly pass
up the opportunity to use him as both a
prop and a metaphor for this week's
direct message one of the ideas which
keeps popping up in the discussions
we're having around here is that old
political labels are becoming more and
more meaningless by the day the terms
progressive and liberal have virtually
nothing to do with each other anymore
and if you're a classical liberal you're
certainly not Aleph tiss conservative
and Republican don't have much to do
with each other today as Trump a
populist
who doesn't focus on social issues like
gay marriage and legalizing marijuana is
now the leader of the GOP
for these reasons as well as the
real-time crumbling of our mainstream
media the battle for freedom now is
between the authoritarians and the
libertarian that is the battle over the
soul of America and the West in general
is now about people who want the
government to have more control over
your life versus the people who want the
government to have less control over
your life I think that by now you
probably know that I fall solidly in the
camp of the people who want the
government to have less control over how
you live and that brings me to my
friendly and trusty stormtrooper beside
me in the original 1977 Star Wars the
stormtroopers were the foot soldiers for
the Galactic Republic a massive evil
military regime who wanted to control
every star system in the galaxy this
would qualify as a Thorat Aryan the
Empire and the stormtroopers were not
keepers of the peace as the emperor had
promised but authoritarian rulers who
wanted to endlessly expand their power
hence their building of the Death Star
to blow up any planet which didn't fall
in line with their desires blowing up a
planet is a pretty good way to get
people to do what you want now there I
talk about the prequels but trust me it
works for this metaphor 2002 Star Wars
Episode two attack of the clones takes
place about 20 years before the original
Star Wars in this film the stormtroopers
at that time known as the clone troopers
were the good guys they allied with the
Jedi
in defense of the Democratic Republic
eventually Chancellor Palpatine who had
consolidated power himself and secretly
ordered the creation of the Clone Army
took control of the stormtroopers and
the Senate and used democracy against
itself at the same time going from
Chancellor to Emperor in 2015 the force
awakens which takes place about 20 years
after the original trilogy the
stormtroopers are again the bad guys
this time in the form of the soldiers
for the authoritarian first order which
has risen from the ashes of the Galactic
Republic one of the heroes of the story
Finn is a stormtrooper gone rogue who
suddenly realizes that he as an end of
individual can chart his own destiny he
puts his collectivist past as a
stormtrooper behind him and he becomes
one of the heroes of the story the point
of all of this is that it isn't this
stormtrooper you should fear it's the
power which commands him any ideology
can be used as a force for good or for
evil and that's why we should be raining
in authoritarianism of any kind even
when it's your sort of authoritarianism
in charge this whole metaphor took place
in a galaxy far far away but the lessons
that it presents are ones we can use
right here on earth joining me to
discuss authoritarianism versus
libertarianism is author professor and
podcaster at matias russell our friends
who learn Liberty of Santa Maura way and
too loosely quote obi-wan Kenobi this is
the episode you've been looking for
[Music]
we're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty today and joining me is an
adjunct professor at William at
University and author of a renegade
history of the United State patias
Russell welcome to the Rubin report
thanks for having me
Thaddeus Russell that is a name sure is
of a man suddenly I feel knows what he's
saying you know it'll be like there's
some gravitas to your name you feel that
first of all my mother gets all the
credit
you know people sort of a compliment me
on my name all the time and I say hey I
had nothing to do with it I wish I could
take credit for it but do you see that
as the pressure I think there's like
just I think it's unfortunate because
you know then I have to be good yeah I
have to sort of say things that make
sense and it's a lot of pressure for me
yeah well you just put on me thanks I
just put an extra dose up there yeah
right now for an hour you're gonna have
to make perfect sense no ma'am because
you know about this this is the Internet
Piper pheasants coming up video people
are going to judge every word that comes
out of your mouth yeah I noticed that
yeah but I'm looking forward to this
because we're gonna talk about
post-modernism I think you have a
slightly different take than some of my
my previous guests you have an
interesting history so let's just dive
into it okay you grew up in a Marxist
household in Berkeley California I've
given a lot of good buzzwords right
there that first sentence what was that
like you could also have said the 60s
and 70s - yeah that's when I was growing
up yeah that's a lot I've been right
there that's a like plus Benning daddy
is right now I'm buying things here I'm
kind of done I mean we can stop the
interview now ya know my parents were
members of a small Trotskyist
sect it's called the International
Socialists and what they did was they
industrialized which meant that they
left their middle class lives and went
into heavy industry and to organize the
proletariat for revolution so my mother
became a clerical worker to organize the
secretaries for revolution my stepfather
who had gone to Exeter Academy and the
University of Chicago he left his world
to become a steel worker and a truck
driver and his mission was to convince
the workers to rise up and bring about a
communist revolution so that was
unsuccessful
yeah I know what caused them to do it
was just generally what was happening
around then with the war yeah it's hard
again it's hard to explain why people
come to particular ideologies but they
chose Berkeley and the 60s they moved
there and sell in with this hardcore
group and that's that was their lives
and so that was my life when I was
growing up and we had meetings in our
house and the comrades were sitting down
downstairs and talking about so I had no
idea what they're talking about it
learned later right but you know it was
heavy Marx's theory and which which
union shop should we infiltrate and
which Factory should we organize and and
then there were visitors to our house
you know there were Black Panthers we
lived about three blocks from the Black
Panthers national headquarters which was
actually in Berkeley not in Oakland and
they were around and sort of hid these
were around and members of the IRA came
and gave speeches and stuff like that so
my mother one of the interesting things
is that my mother was the dominant
figure in my and my family she was the
heavy-duty intellectual actually and so
the idea of you know women being weak or
victimized or unable to compete with men
has always been just a weird thing for
me really an idea because she was always
the dominant force and I always looked
up to her and tried to model myself
after her yeah
so were you once you became of age and
started thinking about these ideas did
you immediately jive with these ideas
did you have pushback or yeah I mean
it's so I will say this my parents as I
recall did not try to indoctrinate me
directly but you can't help it right I
mean if you're if you're raised in a
church family you're going to think that
that's the truth and correct and the way
to be and that's what I said I mean my
mother said that in fact she said this
in one of her speeches but when I was
about 10 years old she said I want to
grow up to be in the is that's what I
want to be I'm going to be a socialist
how do I do that and that was kind of my
mission and I really mean that is when I
went to college I didn't know what
socialism even was yeah and so that was
like I said this it's that I'm going to
learn what socialism is and then become
a socialist and it's sort of what I did
for a while and but that that we're off
yeah so you you write a lot and you talk
about
the outsiders really the rebel I mean
the people the drunk the fringes of
society the people that were probably
add a lot of these meetings now you
don't know no not the people no no
that's a misconception uh yeah my work
so it's okay we know please clean it up
ya know so know the people well okay let
me only tell you how I got there first
so I end up going to Antioch College in
Ohio which is this ultra ultra left
college run by hippies and anarchists
basically and and punk rockers and in
fact well you think that's Evergreen
State I was just going to say no I mean
it's we used to compete with evergreen
but I'm the most politically correct the
most left-wing college in the country
and we always thought oh they don't know
what they're doing we are the true
radical college like that vessel area I
think we were the champions and there's
I have a lot of stories I could tell you
about the insanity at Antioch oh yeah
which is kind of one of the reasons I
started to think twice about this
politics and the culture and well let's
get into give me 100 just let's just
dive into a second because that's not
okay missing job let me give you two
yeah one is just sort of tragic and
disgusting and the others more comical
the tragic and disgusting one was there
were two kids at Antioch one in my third
year who had a an anti-christian art
exhibit and so they had crosses on the
wall and they had a fire in a barrel in
the middle of the room and at one point
they took one of the crosses down and
threw it in the barrel right everyone
there understood this was an
anti-christian statement yeah oh no this
was racism
this was the Ku Klux Klan those kids got
expelled Wow
because it was widely perceived to be an
act of you know vile racist violence and
they had to leave the college and I was
the editor of the newspaper at the time
and I said this was kind of my turning
point for me I said what are you talking
about this is insane it really had this
witch-hunt feel on campus and it felt I
felt guilty and bad for having to come
to their defense simply to explain that
had nothing to do with Raider at all
yeah and then and that there was that
there was a hysteria that really takes
no prisoners I mean you have to be you
have to eliminate the evil once you
identify it you know why do you think
that that ideology breeds that is there
because we're seeing this literally
right now yeah there's something that
goes on in college campuses actually my
mother said this to me when that
happened she said well you know what
they need to double they need to have a
devil yeah as soon as you step on campus
you start reading about the history of
oppression and you know I think a lot of
that's correct in many ways there's a
lot of bad things that have happened in
this country and elsewhere and then you
look around and you're an affluent very
privileged person in this world you're
in the top one percent or more every
college student basically is that
especially at Antioch so there isn't a
devil there is no there is no Bull
Connor you know there isn't there
there's no one like that around here so
you have to find one so what we did was
we kind of focused on administrators the
president you know and his evil
administrator we just Disraeli they
inherently have to be even we assumed
they were evil and they were out to get
us and so we had to get them and so one
day two kids broke in one night two kids
broke into the president's office and
took a [ __ ] on his desk and that was our
that was our statement that was that was
telling him who was who it works at many
levels and what was what yes
yeah so I mean that was those are just
two the most comical you know or worse
things that happened at Antioch in that
way it was also a very liberating place
I mean there was a lot of the hippies
were good in some ways I mean there was
a lot of nudity and smoking pot and lots
of sexual freedom which has gone now in
college campuses and I love that stuff
but I hated this puritanical left-wing
culture yeah and that's when I started
to move against it and then I went to
Columbia for graduate school and
everybody there is a Marxist or a
socialist or maybe a New Deal liberal
but everybody's on the left everybody
and this is Upper West Side of Manhattan
as you know and yeah and I want I needed
to be a socialist and so I started to
study as hard as I could to be a
socialist and be a socialist historian
became a labor historian which what
you're supposed to do but I started
noticing that all of these people didn't
care what clothes they wore they had no
idea what movies were playing they never
watched television they were completely
oblivious to the lives of real people
and in particular well actually I'd say
they were actually hostile to the ways
in which ordinary Americans chose to
spend their leisure time
so popular culture was something that
was bad it was a false consciousness in
fact right this is a this is an idea
from the Frankfurt School from Adorno he
said this he said popular culture is
simply the way the capitalist class
maintains control and so we must do away
with it
I said that's awful it's worse than
awful it's totalitarian yeah there's
many arguments for saying that a lot of
pop culture is nonsense and dribble and
I mock it constantly but also people
need an escape it's also part of human
nature it's these are the things that
rise up that have some resonance with
people yeah I want to say it's better
than an escape so you know a lot of my
work is about Puritanism and it's long
history and that people aren't really
aware of how it carries through today so
the heart of a pure of Puritanism is the
Puritan work ethic and a lot of people
get confused about this they think it's
a working hard to get a nice house or a
big television or a nice car it's not
it's the idea that work in itself no
matter what you get for it is virtuous
so you should work all the time no
matter what you get for it
so popular culture in this country since
it started in early 19th centuries
always been honest and it's not just an
escape from that it's been in a way a
repudiation of that because the Puritans
and their descendants the Victorians in
the 19th century said all these things
are terrible at that time it was dime
novels which were the first novels you
know it was going to the Nickelodeon's
it was gambling with going to the horse
races sports all that stuff they said we
can't do that that's that's evil that's
Satan's work we must avoid that we must
work all the time and raise our families
and that's it so popular culture for me
has essentially been a repudiation of
the Puritan work ethic it's always been
this counter force against that in our
culture and there's this constant fight
between the two so you'll see like in
politics politicians you won't find a
president or a senator until Donald
Trump actually who hasn't criticized
popular culture in some way right
because they are they have to be the
models of the sort of puritanical
repressive good American okay I know
sorry all right no no that's great so is
there when you're discussing it sounds
like there's a religious connotation
there and we
people hear the word puritanical they
think of a religious connection but in
and of itself there isn't really a
religious connection right there they're
the ideas of a religious authority or
something like that but it's not
religious per se it's not necessarily
religious right so one of another
argument I make and I think this might
resonate with you is that modern-day
progressivism and left politics
generally is secular religion it's
really secular Christianity so in
particular I mean I think it's you see
you see they you see a lot of Puritanism
in left-wing politics and that's been
true for a long long time there's
actually a couple of very good books
about are showing that left-wing
intellectuals for the last hundred years
have been a uniformly hostile to popular
culture that until very recently these
sort of hipster communists in Brooklyn
who talked about pop goes until them who
all wear the same glasses we have the
same video where they pretend they do
and I've had arguments with them bake
and their Lennon loved loved the movies
no I mean that Marx Lenin Trotsky all of
them you name it and on all the
intellectuals and universities who are
on the Left have all like Adorno have
all hated pop culture and seen it as
false consciousness because and I said
this once to a professor at Columbia
very prestigious feminist Gender Studies
professor once I said why why do you why
do you hate the fact that so many women
just like to go shopping or like to go
to the movies and she said because I
think they have better things to do with
their time I mean right so that's what
we're not just found Lee judge-made feel
so it's elitist it's judgemental it's at
least authoritarian I think it might be
totalitarian and this is my critique of
the Frankfurt School not post-modernism
different thing yeah and I ride away
again I do want to get very different
things to me its totalitarian because
their idea is that your ideas are wrong
false that's their term they use that
and they're leading you to do things
that are counter to your own interests
though we know what your own interests
are and we know how you should best
arrive at them to gain them so we're
going to tell you what music to listen
to what movies to go see probably no
movies but what you do with your life
real time right it's actually
totalitarian which is
why that crew the people who followed
the Frankfurt School in the 50s and 60s
the left-wing movements that they became
very attracted to during a time were
maoism with third world communism
because that's what maoism looked like
it was this idea that we must rid
ourselves of our bad ideas before the
revolution can happen it's fundamentally
totalitarian it's about the total person
yeah all right so let's back up let's
back up yeah couple things I think
eurabia bouncing around a lot here so I
love this concept of what you said that
Trump was the first one to reject this
because during the election I think a
lot of people noticed and I think what
people partly didn't like about Hillary
was that you know she's on stage with
Katy Perry then Madonna's doing a thing
the day before like just this absolute
connection between pop culture and
politics that started feeling gross it
started feeling like the powers that be
between entertainment and politics were
so in bed together they all hated Trump
and I think that then boosted his
support do you think that's a fair
estimate yeah and you think I was a
calculated move by him or was it just he
had been pinned into a corner because
nobody none of those people were back
and except a few of the deplorable
rejects like Ted Nugent and yeah I mean
I guess I don't have the same critique
of that that you do I have no problem
with what you said but I just I take a
different line on it I mean to me Katy
Perry and Madonna being front people for
Hillary is a contradiction because
Hillary represents second wave feminism
which was read betty Friedan if you
don't agree with me I mean you don't
believe me was a rejection of the
objectification of women in all forms
right so that any showing of skin any
sexual ization of women was bad I need
to be left behind free dance ed in her
book the feminine mystique that women
should become leaders of corporations
leaders of government and that's it and
she has several chapters in that book
that are rejections of sex in particular
and also she attacks gay men for being
eternal boys who are obsessed with sex
and for seducing housewives into being
obsessed with sex
this was free dance whole thing she
thought that women were were themselves
too interested in sex and what they
should be interested in was work
Puritanism here you are right and so
Hillary Clinton is the apotheosis of
that isn't she right she wears the
business suits
she is ultra rational she is ultra
disciplined she her husband get sex
elsewhere you know that he does the bad
stuff right so she is this she's the
perfect second wave feminist so Katy
Perry showing her boobs on stage and you
know Madonna haven't done the same thing
before
that's a rejection that's a
contradiction with second life some of
them so someone's not understanding
something here I think Hillary just used
them but probably isn't really a big fan
of what they're doing right so you know
there's something there's a
contradiction that it needs to be
resolved yeah do you think though that
that contradiction like I think people
see that even even if they don't
understand the full history of it or the
full philosophical underpinnings I think
people kind of see that and I think that
possibly did drive more people to Trump
do you think that makes sense I don't
know I mean it was all jek ssin of all
of it it was like just a rejection of
just this this monstrosity I oh yeah I
think that a lot of people again I don't
know yeah and people I hate the way that
people sort of presume to know what
Trump voters thought yeah right better
know everything other way yeah how are
we doing my name is Thaddius I better
now yeah they you know but I do think
it's reasonable to assume how's that
that a lot of them were rejecting or
reacting to this repressive Puritanism
in Clinton and politics generally that
and which not just cultural not just
about sex it's that you're not allowed
to say all kinds of things if you're in
American politics right it is very
restrictive discourse that's allowed in
American politics I'm sure that was a
lot of what went on in fact I did hear a
lot of people say that Trump says what
he thinks
yeah just that was very attractive to a
lot of people and I that was attractive
to me I didn't like most of what he said
but I did like that he was breaking down
the walls right and Bernie to some
extent was doing that too
you know and so I thought that was very
good even though I didn't like either
one of them in terms of their content
but I did like that they were simply
challenging the walls do you think that
right there is sort of what the next
evolution of politics is going to be
because I've been saying for a while now
I feel like the chessboard has just been
thrown up we've got fertile ground now
we don't know what's going to grow of it
I think there's entry you know the
traditional labels of left-right are
becoming meaningless what really is a
Republican in the age of Trump which is
sort of a different thing than
conservatives of all that do you think
that the next wave of politics is really
going to be about the realignment I hope
so I hope so
I do I know I know you've been talking
about this a lot on your show you know
this this split between authoritarianism
and whatever you want to call it
libertarianism small-l broadly conceived
right right that's what I hope do we
need a better word for that because I
think because I do believe that's what
it is that it's authoritarianism versus
libertarianism but I think when you say
libertarianism people think of it as
some sort of option strange political
parties there is there a better phrase
then yeah I mean so for instance I have
many differences with libertarians so
people often lump me in with them and
but ask a libertarian I mean that's like
a hardcore libertarian about Thaddeus
Russell that's a Leo he's not a
libertarian I have many differences with
them although and some things I very
much agree but they're they their
hostility to or opposition to the state
and state power I'm completely with them
on that
I think markets are very responsive to
consumers needs and I think they advance
humanity in many many ways I don't think
they're perfect I think capitalism is
perfect and that's one of their problems
but anyway I do think that general idea
that basic idea that we should be free
from control by others those in
authority in particular those with state
tower which is the monopoly on violence
right is a good thing so I love that
about them and I love that about this
sort of new formation I see happening
and you're a part of that and some of
your guests are part of that versus
Democrats and Republicans who do want to
control us right liberals and
conservatives who do want to control us
in various ways I would like to see a
new realignment around that I would like
to see us talk about politics in those
terms because the right and left and
they give right no longer mix make much
sense unless you're very specific about
what you mean by them right so we've
talked a little bit more about the left
so
you know my family I'm trying as a
liberal I'm trying to clean up what the
left is and at this point I don't think
that being a liberal and being on the
left or even compatible unfortunately
but let's talk about the right a little
bit right what is right authoritarian
ISM right now right-wing
authoritarianism is sort of what we know
I mean it's using the state to control
people's personal lives so you know it's
they don't want women to choose to be
able to achieve abortions they don't
want us to actually they're very
concerned about popular culture so they
want to control what we watch and listen
to you know they don't like a lot of
Hollywood they don't like a lot of what
happens in the music industry they've
held marches and protests and called for
laws to censor those things and they
also want to control what happens in the
rest of the world in various ways they
want to send out the United States Army
to control how people think and behave
now the thing is that lately and I think
again this is where you've been going a
lot with your show is that there's been
a convergence between the Conservatives
the Republicans and the Liberals the
Democrats on many of these questions so
for instance hip-hop here we go
popular culture if you look at the
reaction to hip-hop over the last 20
years the negative reactions the calls
to censor it
it was tipper gore it was a lot of
feminists and it was Christian
conservatives joining together al
Sharpton was another one who held
marches against hip-hop you know calling
for music companies to shut down these
these artists and censor the lyrics so
there's a lot of convergence around this
authoritarianism yeah so where does
Trump fit into that yeah because he
doesn't care about video game violence
or words that are in rap songs or even
abortion I don't think he particularly
cares about certainly not about gay
marriage so those things that are
thought of as right authoritarianism all
these people that are marching with
hashtag resist are they sort of missing
the boat on who they should be attacking
on they would have been a great thing if
he had had more than two or three people
in the world who agreed with him and
we're in Washington DC yeah things right
so unfortunately he brought just a tiny
little crew to Washington and had to
fill all these posts you know all these
jobs and the only people available
unfortunately were Christian
conservatives and generals right and so
what
we have it in Mike Pence right so Mike
Pence comes from the Christian
conservative right conservative wing and
they've gotten their you know their hold
on him sessions I think is another one
right the who actually thinks that
marijuana is dangerous to people I mean
it's it's phenomenal the guy is an
absolute neanderthal on this stuff I do
think that he's not going to be
successful because I think that that war
has been won by us you know but but it's
it's it's unfortunate that Trump I think
he feels the holdin to them he can't
hold any power without the Christian
conservative base and so he's not being
really forceful in his championing of
popular culture which he comes right out
of right now I mean look at who he is
he's even the DeMuth of his wife as a
model and you know all the rest of it I
mean it's so yeah so Trump and that's
one of the reasons I think that he makes
people crazy in fact I actually think
that's the main reason he makes both
sides liberals and conservatives
absolutely lose their stuff which is
that he is that he breaks those rules
cultural rules so if you look at if you
look at Puritanism right what I was
talking about the work ethic
what does Donald Trump do mmm he got a
bunch of money from his dad and he kind
of lives large on his private jets
everything is in you know everything is
covered in gold and what who does that
other than Donald Trump rappers yeah you
think about this right he does a lot of
the stuff that you know the bad black
people have done they celebrate their
bodies and they don't care about you
know conventional rules and norms and
Buchwald morality and all that stuff and
you know he's he's not shy about talking
about sex that's also something you
can't do with an absolute taboo he
breaks all those cultural rules I
actually think that's why they go crazy
about Donald Trump in a bad way because
basically they don't know how to fight
it because they're constrained by sort
of other rules right it's it's so
fundamental to who they are and their
what their world is when we walk around
in America generally speaking we don't
talk about sex we just don't it's the
silence that we impose on ourselves we
all are proud of when we work hard even
if we don't make a nickel for it right
it is so central to who we are we've
internalized it it's not like people
walk around saying oh I'm a Puritan and
here
it's just it's completely deeply
embedded inside of us since the Puritans
got here and that's what Trump just
seems to not seems to be oblivious to
sort of the depth under mental American
culture and I would say it's really a
middle class culture so working-class
people of all colors have generally
speaking in immigrants to have kind of
avoided that stuff they haven't
internalized it of course because
they're sort of outside of the the realm
of power and they're outside of
citizenship right and so for whatever
reason I don't know why Trump is much
more like them even though he's always
been a rich kid he sort of adopted that
kind of working-class indifference to
bushwa morality and it people can't
stand that what does that tell you about
politics sort of between the ideas and
just the cult of personality yeah you
know as someone that you obviously care
about ideas you have a command of yeah
because you were born out of certain
ideas that you later challenged and it's
sort of incorporated into what you do
now but basically everything you said
it's just this is just cult of
personality of what you say there's a
fundamental very depressing problem that
I'm sort of just coming to grips with or
coming to terms with now in my own life
which is that and I sort of known this
all along but it's really hitting me
hard is that even with the Internet even
though I think people are better
informed now than ever before because of
that the vast vast vast majority of
Americans don't know anything about
politics so the obviously been spending
time on Twitter this is a problem no
matter what your politics are as a
public political person or a public
intellectual you know people don't even
like that word and and it all it means
is you're a lover of ideas that you're
curious about big ideas and you talk
about ideas that's it you know people
don't even like it when you use that
yeah it smug Duntov I know
smug is the word of them called recently
um more than one it's a it's a problem I
mean for what we do right it's you know
we so that's why we those of us in this
little world talk to each other most of
the time yeah right because most
Americans have never heard of Syria much
less know anything about it you know uh
most Americans I mean look at the polls
it's just most Americans I think don't
know who the Vice President is it's
something like that I mean they could
they can't identify Washington
DC on a map huge portions of the
American public don't know anything is
that just a function of our success that
we are perhaps the most successful
nation in the history of the world we
have done tremendous amounts of good
we've done plenty of bad at the same
time we brought in more people from
every walk of life all of these things
we've created the system that basically
still is pretty great and what you get
out of that after the sausage is you get
sort of a dumbed down thing because
people have video games and have leisure
and sports and all those things yeah so
I think those are good things that I'm
ethics yeah well III think yeah it's
pretty great that doesn't mean there
aren't problems and I wish more people
cared about ideas and all that but that
it's just a function of success is yeah
some of this yeah you don't need to care
about stuff you don't need to think you
don't need to read Foucault and you can
spot all you want about what he thinks
but you don't need to read them right
because no one does so there's no one's
ever checks you on it right but that
right um so yeah I mean it's like I
often say to people like you and me it's
like what are we sure we want to be
doing this wouldn't we have a better
time in a better life if we were just
following sports instead in a night a
sport is funny I had Jason Whitlock from
Fox News went on a couple weeks ago and
he was so you know clearly passionate
noses thoughts and all that stuff about
politics in the wider world I've no any
left I was like man that guy gets to
talk about sports I was like that would
be pretty great if I was in NBA analyst
no I know what we do look that's that's
you I don't know I mean aren't we can
flow I got any form I love I love it
well you do but you're also not Richard
by it
yeah it's exhausting when when when the
articles and publications call me all
right extremists yeah you know and then
I have to go well now do I want to spend
my day fighting this or just letting it
be or put it all it's fighting that's
what it is
right and so half the time I love the
fight and half the time I hate it I
don't know what else to say I mean I
don't know what else I could do I mean I
would love it to be like a boxing coach
instead but I don't think I can and I'd
like to be in the NBA right probably not
deep so you know you know Jews used to
dominate basketball I know in this
country oh you know that I know I know
whether that they were a lot of Jews in
the early days of the NBA yeah now I
dominated
to a predominated 40 with the badge so
you could bring that back you know now
that I think there are no Jews and I'm
good you could be the first and not wand
you that's pretty sad I've heard that
Jordan Farmar is half Jewish I believe
that's about it man they got him out
they found out about it yeah I think
they actually sent it to Israel but
right through total side point I want to
focus a little more on that on that
right authoritarian thing because it
isn't the part of the authoritarian
stuff that I focus on a lot so I do want
to spend a little more time there ok
part of it doesn't make sense to me like
it seems to me that on something like
gay marriage if the right that
supposedly believes in states rights and
in the individual and in local limited
government all those things they had
such an easy opportunity to do the right
thing with gay marriage now of course it
got screwed up because of the Christian
conservatives but even right now with
marijuana as you're talking about with
Jeff Sessions it's like you guys are the
ones that are supposed to care about
limited government and not having the
government tell people what they can do
in their own home why are they unable to
take a principled position hear it well
I don't know about being ok well I think
for me that did I lead too much or no no
no no I think that conservative or
republican authoritarianism is different
in a very important way and it's the
reason that I like you focus much more
than left authoritarianism which is that
they are dumber really they are less
effective at getting authoritarian
politics out there and distributed and
and bought into sessions this is what I
was talking about sessions right good
luck buddy like convincing America to
roll back legalization of pot it ain't
going to happen right you're certainly
not going to convince anyone of this
stuff I mean no one no one believes
other than Jeff Sessions really the pot
is harmful to you in the ways he's
talking about but they what does that
say that that even President Obama was
still having the feds shut down the
local things like here in California is
my point that is exactly what I'm saying
here so that sessions won't be able to
do it
Obama could because everybody loved
Obama because Obama played by all the
rules because he was the perfect
American man and he was black and so he
he kind of fixed our bad history for us
too he
feel better he was our salvation he was
he was perfect he was almost a Jesus
figure and that's real and I mean that
people really did treat him that way and
I don't think that's an exaggeration if
you look at it right and so he could
send in the feds to shut down marijuana
dispensaries and no one batted an eye
yeah certainly on the left but why did
he oh why did yeah I see what you're
saying on the water he can get away with
it but why do you think he did if most
likely he doesn't really care about
marijuana laws I don't know I would say
that he liked like people in the
progressive left and I include liberals
in this are interested primarily in
social control so they need and that's
not it's not saying that they're evil
that's just who they are they like a
well-ordered society so I don't know but
I would suspect and look at Obama he's
like the paragon of discipline right he
is actually the perfect Puritan at least
as far as we know right I would say that
part of it that he didn't like the fact
that people were violating federal law
and I think getting high I think he now
sees as disruptive right it's not a good
thing so look at his sermons here you go
sermons or lectures or speeches whatever
you want to call them interesting too
against black culture which people sort
of don't pay attention to but he gave
many every time a guy got in front of a
black audience he would start lecturing
them about watching too much ESPN and
about how they needed to pull up their
pants and how much how they needed to
work harder and raise their children
right and stop eating Popeyes Chicken
google it I mean he went and Michelle
did the same thing this really Stern
admonitions of black culture so I think
that's all of the piece I think that
probably plays into why he did go after
the dispensaries yeah there's a lot
there so really where we started before
we went on this 20-minute roundabout was
I was mentioning the the you know the
outcast sort of the the drunks and all
those people and then I said I was sort
of like some of the people that were in
your house growing up and you were
making instinctive those are not the
same thing so let's think you go back to
the house good I had it there I knew we
were going to get that was
good yeah so the the Communists in my
house growing up were puritanical
because as I said earlier you know
communists and socialists have always
been puritanical again this is lots of
literature has been written on this this
is not just me talking Lenin and Marx
were opposed re Lenin and Trotsky were
opposed to homosexuality not because
some of sexuality was sort of being bad
in itself but because it was decadent so
decadence was the problem for communists
throughout the 20th century they thought
like Adorno did later that it was this
thing that was leading the working class
the decadence popular culture
consumerism was leading the
working-class astray what the working
class should be doing instead was
organizing themselves for revolution now
here's what they understood this is why
it's all logical they understood that
when you control or manage a whole
society which is what they wanted
everyone to do that requires tremendous
discipline you can't be going to the
movies right if you're going to be
managing the economy right and so that's
what they said and this is was this was
their argument we need to instill this
perfect proletarian discipline was the
phrase in the Soviet Union and elsewhere
and so my parents comrades came out of
that tradition they were Trotskyists you
know they came out of that and they
understood that so they may have watched
some television but they didn't they
thought at best it was just an escape
right and what we really need to be
doing is studying GDP figures right and
so that we can manage the economy
everyone should be doing that everyone
should be an engineer and everyone
should be ready to have meetings all day
long and all night long to organize our
society so it's so interesting because I
don't as you're saying that I was
thinking that recently I've been telling
this thing about how comedy I think is
dying right now - that there aren't
comics willing to cross line we've got
Bill Maher apologizing for a word even
though no one in their right mind thinks
he's racist we've seen so many leftist
progressive comedians just making the
same Trump jokes over again and not
really pushing the limits of what comedy
is but with what you're saying it really
does make sense why they almost can't be
funny this is what I've been saying that
these progressives who
are shutting down pop culture in these
ways are true to their heritage this is
what progressives I mean the
progressives the original ones of the
early twenty century did they shut down
the Nickelodeon's they did they in every
city in the country progressives
launched these cameras can you tell
people at Nickelodeon czar oh sorry
there's a lot of people my younger
audience is going to think you mean blue
with the green goo sorry that's not what
you mean yeah the the Nickelodeon
network is named after the cinemas in
which started in the Lower East Side of
New York but grew and spread all over
the country which were five cent cinemas
you could go and put a nickel in and you
could watch a movie yeah oh I'm sure
they probably wouldn't go after the
green boots some point too because
there's got to be some racial
connotation today yeah so the
progressives in all the big cities shut
down those Nickelodeon's because the
working-class was watching burlesque you
know or you know just or things that
weren't about work and you know
discipline and war and so yeah it's it
they're being true to the heritage yeah
we should have culture that is
completely austere right and and not fun
or funny in those ways that's why the
left is so unfunny right think about it
I mean they're so earnest they're so
earnest that they can't make a joke well
that's the thing they've been burned
Peppe and tank
yeah and kekaa stan and all that they
birthed it because it's these people
online that have just had it with the
political pregnant so now they're
sending out frogs with swastikas just to
get a reaction out of you yeah and
people that think it's hate speech my
heresies been I had Gavin McInnes on my
show and you know it became very clear
to me about five minutes in this is
what's happening he's hilarious much of
what he says is either racist or pretty
damn close and the content of what he's
saying I have a lot of trouble with I
don't know how serious he is about it
but it's it's clearly right-wing in
pretty bad ways according to my politics
but he's really really funny he has the
freedom to do that comedy requires
freedom Jim goad is another one you know
he he just approached me he wants to be
on my podcast and he but he and I
started looking at his writing much of
what he says is probably racist probably
sexist probably homophobic
but he's hilarious he's very very funny
so what do you do yeah what another want
to have you that what do you do with
that you personally what do you do with
that when you're sitting across from
something like that
right I don't know I laugh yeah and I'm
troubled and I feel like if they are not
however I feel like if they like with
Gavin McInnes
he has no real power right I mean no
one's going to listen to him and write
some policy based on this okay you know
you could say he contributes to the
Trump phenomenon but what's the Trump
phenomenon I mean there is no Trump
phenomenon anymore the generals have
taken over basically you know yeah once
they attach themselves to any movement
that might cease state power
oh then give me an ak-47 right but these
guys are so marginalized people talk
about being marginalized the
marginalized are those guys and what
they represent it's so interesting you
say that because that's the other reason
that I focus on the left is not just
because I come from it but also because
I see that's where all the power is
seated the conversation seated there
Hollywood it's even they're all buzzing
so when they get you know the three
white supremacists to show up at a
meeting somewhere and then of course the
media blows it out of proportion as if
there's Nazis you know rampaging through
the street it's like you're you just
need that need that belief do you think
that's a fair oh absolutely
oh yeah none of it yeah I mean so they
control most of the media it's just true
okay
liberals liberals mostly not really
socialists but the Liberals control the
media for the most part other than Fox
News and Fox that's eight well by the
way if you've ever been in the Fox News
greenroom you'll know that there's a lot
of liberals who even work there right oh
the people behind the scenes they stud I
knew what gay people that work there and
all sort of York City upper website oh
yeah exactly and they control academia
and they control what's now being called
the deep state whatever you know if
that's yeah so there's a whole other guy
whatever but you know in terms of the
civil servants right to work in
Washington DC and work in all the state
capitals it's over we know this is
overwhelmingly liberal so yeah this is
why I get upset because they control the
world that I operate in they determine
my fate in many ways so I know that just
because of the things that we talk about
here every week when you say the word
liberal that a certain amount my
audience is going to go wait a minute
does he need
classical liberal or does he mean
progressive or leftist or something you
a it's obvious to me you're making that
distinction but the word liberal has now
been so muddied that yeah some ways it's
not even yet worth the progressives who
shut down the Nickelodeon's and the turn
of the 20th century
they're the ones who change than the
meaning of the word they they seized it
sort of after World War one and said oh
no we're liberals and people are like
what are you talking about you're not
liberals you want the state to control
much of the economy and and much of our
lives but they started to use that word
and it's stuck and so once once the New
Deal happens in the 1930s Franklin
Roosevelt becomes another Jesus figure
and he calls himself liberal and they
people call his movement liberal then it
that was it that was the moment the
turning point no this is all of course a
repudiation of classical liberalism
which is about the individual you know
having some autonomy or at least freedom
from the state and its power do you
think that people like us can win that
word back that's what I'm thinking about
a lot lately [ __ ] I like making this
argument for liberalism versus the left
I just don't think it's a liberal
movement any okay and I know that I
brought a lot of people to it and have
many allies that are doing similar work
you included but do you think it's
possible like the word liberal is now so
tainted that in the broader sense maybe
we can't build something around that
word not to say the ideas can't be used
in another way yeah so I'm not sure I
want to so I'm not a classical liberal
and I don't love classical liberalism I
like some of it but the the Puritan
notion of the repressed individual who
never talks about sex and only has sex
to procreate and who works all the time
that's actually at the center of
classical liberalism so if you read John
Locke and you read the founding fathers
this is what they say you know we must
regulate ourselves so that the state
doesn't have to so it's a it's a
cultural Puritanism it's good that they
don't want the state regulating us in
those ways so I like that I like that
love rights but they say for that to
happen
for that to be possible we must
constantly police ourselves so the cop
becomes internal the police the
policeman is inside of us so I don't
love that yeah
yeah yeah that's interesting because
I've never thought of it in that I know
exactly we're talking about but to me
that was more of just the sign of the
times than versus now because are we all
policing ourselves in our own way I mean
every day you get up and you don't do
everything that every whim that you want
to do and every turn the urge that you
want to so we're all sort of doing that
driven by living right oh yeah sure is
not I mean it's not it wasn't a sign of
the times that they made this argument
I mean Locke and the founding fathers
the whole first chapter of my book
renegade histories on this I mean if you
think about its consistent right they
wanted the people or at least some of
the people many of the people to control
the country take it away from the king
and run it themselves and they
understood this thing that the the
Leninists understood a century later
which is that oh to do that Jesus we
thought it like learn a bunch of stuff
and we've got to stop you know going to
the [ __ ] fights and stop smoking cigars
no really and stop drinking most of all
and because we got work to do we've got
to run this country democracy I say is
puritanical for that reason so it's
interesting because as you know you say
you work with learn Liberty their
classical liberal organization they sent
you to me I just wanted what's makeup
nobody I want make a point of saying
that's why it's a beautiful thing that
you're doing with them
because you just said I am NOT a
classical oh yeah where do you if you
had to give yourself a label I know you
don't want to get hung up on that kind
stuff but I sense a lot of classical
liberals suffer knew I sent some
libertarian stuff from you I said some
utility of the state from you what the
hell is that I don't know let's make up
a new word I don't know I mean I don't
know I I am I have sort of culturally I
guess I'm an artistic I suppose I I am
anti-authoritarian I'm anti Authority
it doesn't mean I want to demolish
Authority and remove Authority in fact I
like that there are some people in this
world who want to take charge because I
don't want to do that work right I don't
want to do that work yeah it's weird
right that there are some people who
just want to manage everything and like
take control and take care of everything
I don't want to determine who picks up
your garbage on Monday morning I mean
that's fine I'm glad you want to do that
I'd rather play video games or whatever
it is right and so I don't know what
that is I mean it's um that's why I like
a lot of libertarianism you know
obviously because they want the state
out of our lives but a lot of
libertarians
have this classical idea of the
self-regulating individual there right
at the middle of it and so I don't like
that at all because they're kind of not
fun either they're actually a lot of
libertarians remind me of the Socialists
that I grew up with
they're very stodgy and very kind of
uptight and controlled and not
interested in the real world and the
pleasures in the real world all the
pleasure they get is from reading books
which I understand but there's more to
life than that yeah you know this past
week was or about a week ago is VidCon
which is where all these the youtubers
get together I didn't go but a lot of
the people that are sort of in my
youtube circles most of them are younger
than me were there and it seemed like
what I could gather was they were the
fun group that there's these people on
the Left they're screaming about third
wave feminism and all this stuff and
then they're at a YouTube conference
it's not a lot of many people on the
traditional right but that this new
group whatever this thing is of these
sort of half liberal libertarian mix
whatever but they're the fun group and
that's what's attracting people I think
that was probably a lot of what was in
the middle of gamergate which was that
there's these kids playing video games
who like looking at women with big boobs
and have that and enjoying it right and
that was about it I think for most of
them I would imagine right they like
shooting people right virtually yeah you
know and watching the heads explode
which you're not allowed to do by the
way that's another form of repression
that the Puritans and the Victorians
instituted we can't fight each other in
the streets but anarchic and disorderly
we have to let the state do all the
killing for us right we get the monopoly
on violence the state does so you can't
do that anymore so like boxing was
shunned for a long time all these things
you know and so I think I think video
games represent sort of a return of the
repressed to use Freud's term yeah you
know in that way because if these kids
are doing stuff you're not allowed to do
it through these video games which is
kill and have sex or at least some kind
of sex
ready sexual in that way and it's fun
now we know that this didn't cause them
to go out and shoot people we know that
it didn't cause them to go out and rape
people we know this from many many many
studies that are great every study yeah
every study okay so we just know that
and so they were having fun doing the
stuff that you're not allowed to do or
even a
rest you're not even allowed to express
those desires in this culture right and
then all of a sudden you have these
people coming in swooping in and telling
them that not only what they're doing
just their thoughts their feelings are
bad but that it's going to cause another
Sandy Hook and another mass rape
somewhere and that it's it's the cause
of the subjugation of women well it
doesn't make sense to these kids and I
imagine and it's like we were just
having fun in our mom's basement yeah we
by the way we have zero institutional
power in this country right nothing
nothing and you're telling us suddenly
we are the most powerful people in the
world now by the way I'm speaking for
them now why what here's what's so
amazing to me we should have a game or
get hat for you yeah here's what's so
amazing to me it's like why are
feminists or went or any wise anyone so
concerned about what those people think
like that's what it becomes important in
a lot of demonym scores is what we think
what men think well that all that does
is sort of rien scribe the patriarchy
right what we think what we do is what's
important but I men do and think is
what's important
well how about just say I'm going to do
what I want to do and many feminists by
the way have done this there's a
different strain of feminism that I love
which has been called sex-positive
feminism or independent feminism but
that's sort of where the christina hoff
sommers
I know she doesn't book that one effect
but she but more just like let them do
their thing
maybe yeah so I had a guest on my show
her name is Ana Arrowsmith she's a she
was a feminist in and she hated
pornography she thought it you know
degraded women and then she was walking
down the street in Soho in London which
is the red-light district basically in
London thinking and watching all these
shops full of these you know video
videos sex all over and she was turned
on by it and she thought oh wait a
minute I'm turned off but yeah but I
don't like that so you know I'm going to
do I'm going to make my own porn and so
she started making your own porn she
became the biggest female pornographer
in the world and did it on our own terms
and it's all hardcore there's nothing
she doesn't hold any held anything back
she just makes it nicer looking and the
men are better looking at her and that's
it to me that's feminism do it on your
own
make your own world right instead of
worrying constantly about what I want
and what I think yeah how unhealthy do
you think just having to talk about
politics all the time is I don't mean
what we're doing right that so I don't
mean for the people that have these
conversations about ideas and that but I
mean for the average person that all day
long now because of social media is
harping about every little decision that
happens in the government and that I try
--xx me as it's becoming it's starting
to like really rot people's minds or
something like I would argue that a good
government is one that's small enough
that you wouldn't have to talk about it
all the time
now there's probably good counter
arguments to that but the idea that
people are all day worried about this it
seems like a real problem well so when
you say people you know I mean how many
people are we talking about again I
think it right it's hard to gate is the
I think it's a lot of people talking to
each other right I think it's a pretty
small world that we inhabit or that we
observe right I think that I think most
of all what is it 25 percent of
Americans are on Twitter okay so that's
a quarter it's a pretty big chunk but of
those how many just reads with Katy
Perry's feed right I mean I think that
those who do polish candy bar bizarrely
political though because doing stuff
with Hillary so okay yeah but let's say
you know what's called political Twitter
you know I don't know but how many
people are there right and how many
people there are just you know just
check in on the Democratic Party's
latest you know issue announcements
right I think it's pretty small world
I'm not too worried about the population
in general but I do think that the world
that you and I have chosen to live in is
pretty uncomfortable and I'd say since
the election in particular is nearly
intolerable so I used to be a Twitter
addict and then since the election it's
actually been really hard it's not been
fun to go on Twitter it really almost
never is fun it almost always makes me
sad or angry and so I watch it less you
know and I don't know I think that maybe
the next phase we're going to go through
the Twitter will become something else
so there will be alternatives to it and
you know it's just people talking the
thing is to just keep going and not I
know it's hard but to not let the eggs
with the five followers get to you they
get to me but we just have to keep going
if we want to do
yeah what about the amount of time that
we're spending on this I think that's
really what I meant they're not just not
just the griping but the amount of time
people are worried about these things
like the broader people yeah I mean well
the thing that I don't like is there is
the policing that goes on it's a
constant policing right you said this
and that you shouldn't say that you
shouldn't think this you shouldn't feel
this you need to check yourself you need
to watch yourself it's all it's a
totalitarian language um which again by
the way comes out of the Frankfurt
School it does which you know their
argument was that language is the tool
of the oppressor against the oppressed
and so we need to we need to recapture
the language and make it our own to
bring about revolution that was the
Frankfurt School it's it's a
totalitarian impulse it's a totalitarian
politics it's no fun to be around and I
think that's the thing people are just
they're repudiating it sort of tacitly
in that they are they're watching their
video they're playing video games
instead they're watching television
instead they're not engaging in this
discourse you and I are masochists
because I do it most people are not
masochist in that way so that's to me
the cause for hope
yeah it's so funny because I enjoy 90%
of it there is that 10% of just you know
when people are maliciously misquoting
me or writing things that are blatantly
not true the rest of the interaction I
can basically deal with and I do love
the battle of ideas but believe me I
hear you there's there's like an
unspoken thing that we can do here that
I can't quite current quantify in words
so I'm Kerry so all this being said you
have an interesting myth you know
mix-match of politics and culture and
all that stuff is there anyone in
politics right now that you like that
you go nice guy kind of gets it no
fiance meaning like electoral politics
yeah just anyone right now or well now
who in the public space in general like
is there like a couple is there anyone
in electoral politics there's no one
yeah I mean in fact I thought Trump was
interesting in those ways that he was at
least raising these questions for the
first time I mean I can't stand most of
what he's for in terms of policy but he
was raising these questions for the
first time so I got to talk about
that was great thank you for the
opportunity now leave office and so just
please don't do anything wait on office
is the best thing but no in electro
politics there's no one because they are
part of the machine or at least they
want to be part of the machine so being
part of the Machine means making
yourself a cog right
uninteresting in my you know
uninteresting to me there are very few
cultural radicals left there are a few
sort of sex radicals there's like three
you know I find them interesting you
know people who say yeah we should talk
about sex we should be able to express
our desires openly it's better sex is a
good thing sex is not about they almost
don't exist the 60s had that the new
left and the counterculture had some
people there who were quite interesting
in that way but they're gone and it's
very sad yeah it's interesting there's
this writer I forget what he writes for
even but I don't II saw this thing where
he took a screen capture of his screen
and one of his tabs had hentai more and
on it which I guess is it's like on
foreigners islands I'm like some cartoon
porn but he's a lefty so all these
people on this all right you know these
midweek so anything goes over here they
were all attacking him and I was like do
you guys not see the irony and hey
you're doing here like it wasn't illegal
what he was doing it was some odd thing
you know well I mean but I thought you
guys are the free being you know
alrighty I mean a lot of the left I
would imagine it would attack him too I
mean they have in the past right that's
you know that's the objectification of
women so we can't have that right ya
know it's it's it's not fun but so in
terms of ya know I guess I guess it's
sort of my mission to kind of bring back
that kind of and it is left-wing here's
here's part of my politics suits like
that sort of left cultural radicalism
back into political discourse which is
just doesn't exist
really so when you say left cultural rat
and radicalism you you actually do mean
freedom mmm-hmm in that context it
doesn't sound like something that's of
the modern left now but that's what you
find you're talking about real great art
you're talking about great comedy all of
those things yeah I'm talking about
Lenny Bruce yeah and Richard Pryor right
you talk about stand-up comics those are
my heroes those are my original heroes
Richard Pryor is my original hero
because he did that he just said
you said well you're not supposed to say
he said what you're not supposed to say
that's what great comedy is that makes
us laugh and that's what makes them so
brilliant you know and yeah I don't know
that's lost but it's certainly being
challenged
oh it's being it's just being squeezed
Lenny Bruce yeah went to prison yeah for
that okay and so do we want to return to
that do we want to put comedians in jail
for saying things you're not supposed to
say not doing things you're not supposed
to do saying things you're not supposed
to think giving voice to the taboo
giving voice to the forbidden that's
what they do
shouldn't we have that imagine what
would be happening if George Carlin
would be 80 years old right now was
still trying to go to college campuses
they'd be screaming about this old white
man who's saying all of these things
this is a massive problem that's why by
the way I was so dispirited I guess by
Bill Maher's apology because everyone
knows he's not racist so I'm not saying
that I'm going to sit here and want to
use that word if it bothers people of
course speech has consequences I
understand that but the apology struck
me as man a comedian who's been the hero
of the left has to now bow to them this
strikes me as a major problem okay are
you ready to get into more trouble Dave
let's go okay so [ __ ] is arguably the
most important word in American history
if we don't use that word
we're not serious about understanding
American history we're not serious about
understanding that this culture you can
be an anti-racist or a racist or
anything but if you don't talk about
that word and use that word the way it's
been used in history not to hurt people
not as an epithet but to simply refer to
it right we can't do that
we're not grown-ups here we're not being
serious about ideas about history about
our culture about America we can't
understand it and that's really what it
is it's avoiding these ideas rather than
hitting them head-on
people talk about slavery as if they
know anything I don't know anything
about slavery they just know that it was
wrong and there was whippings all day
long it was nothing but rape and torture
having never read a thing about the
history of slavery it's the same thing
right it's it's when you
moralize write about ideas that is
anti-intellectual that is saying oh this
thing is outside the realm of discourse
this is outside the realm of inquiry
it's anti intellectual and it's lazy and
I would say it leads to things that are
worse it leads to things like Donald
Trump because you are repressing again
these ideas and there are people who
just won't be repressed and they're
going to come back and they're going to
say yeah you're playing identity
politics you're saying there's blackness
and whiteness and you're black and I'm
white well okay fine now I'm going to
say I'm about whiteness and being white
so that's the problem there I mean it's
it's it's a very bad thing to avoid we
have to use these words yeah it's so
interesting because I've heard people
make that argument I saw my friend
Michael Shermer make that argument about
that you're just creating an identity
politics of white people and I saw him
get into a fight with some lettuce
professor on Twitter and I by the way I
offered her an opportunity to come here
and defend her I guess she declined but
I so obviously see that but it also
leads to all sorts of other cultural rot
because by taking the word out of Huck
Finn
well now you well that was a book that's
it's not only stood the test of time but
now you're altering the original meaning
not to mention that Huck Finn was
anti-racist book yeah which adds Bill
Maher has been anti places but the point
needs to be made that if it were racist
we still have to use the word right not
as an epithet again not the way the
racists use the word but we have to be
able to talk about racism
we're not here's that here's the
terrible irony that by not being allowed
to use that word we are not allowed to
talk about racism we're not allowed to
study it think about it ticket seriously
right it's like in Germany you're not
allowed to basically talk about Nazism
unless you just sort of moralize it
really quickly wouldn't you rather as a
Jew or an anti-nazi or any would you
rather a study it really hard really
closely if you don't want to return to
that yeah well it's why I mean as a free
speech guy it's why I'm completely
against the laws that you know
criminalize Holocaust denial because
they're not going to stop tonight
they're just going to go into their
secret little places and I'd rather have
all there are more real Nazis in Germany
than than in the United States what we
are allowed to talk about it
yeah yeah but okay so you just so you
said the word now I know certainly
people are not angry because I have not
said the word uh-huh
oops while sitting here with you right
the second you know that there's a
certain cost there you know you mean
like yeah and it's just cuz you just
sort of shifted past that what I think
you get your you've made your sort of
philosophical point now it's just yeah
so just I would just say listen to what
I say after the word because I very
clearly put forward why we should use
that word and I'm pretty sure what I
said was anti-racist yes anti-racist
that anti racism requires using the word
[ __ ] and that's why all this has been
flipped so that at Evergreen State to
bring us back to 40 minutes ago at
Evergreen say you have a professor Brett
Weinstein who was being anti-racist and
now he is smeared a racist so I guess
that's what it is when you don't deal
with the truth honestly you end up
having to destroy anyone who even gets
close to it yeah yeah yeah evergreen is
um not a good look
I would say you know it's I don't know
you want to go into this too much but
you know a lot of there's a lot that's
not said about what what causes this
craziness on campuses which is that you
know there's a monopoly that no one
talks about no one's even aware of this
in fact I wasn't even aware of it until
recently the Department of Education and
the federal government authorizes
accreditation agencies accreditation
agencies accredit colleges and
universities and they have all these
rules it's not you can't just become a
college you have to have all these
things in place for them to accredit you
without accreditation the world doesn't
take you seriously employers don't take
you seriously right that credentialing
is crucial to this okay it's the federal
government at the head of this whole
thing of this monopoly that they have
right then on top of that there's
another monopoly within it which is
tenure the tenure system right so after
seven years if you're lucky and you're
good and you follow the rules and you
say the right things you get tenure and
you're there forever now who do you
think you're going to hire once you have
tenure someone who is
whose contrary to your ideas or someone
who might agree with you someone who
makes you look good or someone who
challenges you hence we have this
uniformity of opinion in academia which
is supported defended bolstered by this
federal government state and forced
monopolies no one knows this that's
what's going on here
third thing last thing you add to this
this system of affirmative action okay
which brings people onto campus who
according to the rules of affirmative
action have less training in academic
work than other kids so when they get
there of course it's going to be more
difficult for them to do the academic
work also it has been stated the purpose
of diversity and affirmative action is
to have these people represent their
race right and so imagine how crazy that
would make you feel in a classroom when
you're like one black kid or one
whatever kid or - black is out of 30 and
everybody knows why you're there and
you're supposed to represent your race
and people are wondering assuming that
you don't have the credentials that they
do that would make me crazy too and so I
almost everything that's been said in
the race discourse on campuses over the
last three years have been to me
fraudulent or hysterical and much of it
has been totalitarian by the way but I
think there is something at the bottom
of it that's legitimate there's a
legitimate grievance that African
American students have on colleges
that's not addressed the tools they have
to talk about this are only Martin
Luther King and Rosa Parks and Malcolm X
and you know Bull Connor and oppression
and slavery so that's the way that's
that's the way they talk about it and
that's that's unfortunate and that's the
fault of their professors we need to
give them language we will talk about
what's really going on which is not good
it's not fun for them yeah it's hard I
absolutely get that it could feel
oppressive really that word is the word
I would use if I were them but it's not
the oppression they're talking about
there is no physical threat to them
there never have been right there but
they're yeah interesting yeah I
referenced my interview Jason Whitlock
allure but he said something to that
fact that basically the oppression is
different now and you have to then
change tactics you can't be doing
fighting the way that say Jesse Jackson
or a al Sharpton is using the language
of the old thing when there's a whole
different system in play right right
where you could get more natural allies
yeah and I'm only talking about academia
yeah I'm not talking about being a 19
year old in Ferguson Missouri that's a
different ballgame entirely I'm talking
about academia I know that world very
well those are the rules of the world
and that's what happens to these black
kids they're plucked out of these
neighborhoods put in these classrooms
and said oh go ahead represent your race
we're going to pay you to do that well
that's going to make you crazy so that's
a different it's what I call liberal or
racial liberalism it's a this idea of
the representative race and the idea
that with it we will give them the
chance to prove themselves that they can
be just like us
so there's an assimilationist impulse in
there too or an assimilationist
expectation we're going to show the
world that these black people can be
just like us which by the way is kind of
white supremacist in a way right because
they're saying well our world of course
is the best one Harvard of course is the
best place to be that's incredibly
elitist and superior and probably white
supremacist because Harvard of course is
historically a very white institution
yeah
so just let people do what they want to
do we don't have to expect them to go to
Harvard all right well I suspect we're
going to do this again but I want to ask
you one final thing we and I think you
it sort of been through line two what
you're talking about
I sense sort of like an alternate so
there's sort of a world weariness view
and then also like a total sense of
opportunity do you think these things
are in like 50/50 with you because I
have a lot of that too I am definitely
world.we I worry about the state of the
world but what is going to happen to the
Western world and society and all these
trends that I talked about that I think
are so dangerous and yet I could never
do this if I didn't have optimism care
about the ideas so I sense that
constantly about how where are your
percentages where do you and all that to
get out of bed and do what you do so
people are wealthier than ever before
there is less poverty in the world than
ever before and some very optimistic
about that
going forward I constantly worry about
war I do I mean you know world war two
was not that long ago Vietnam wasn't
that long ago millions of people died in
that war that could happen literally at
any minute you know thinking about the
Middle East and these new coalition's
that are forming right now we have the
Saudi the Sunni side with the Saudis and
the US and Israel against the Shia side
with Iran and Syria and Russia and if
turkey makes its decision to go with the
with Toshiya which it very well might be
occurred then look what we have there we
have two huge military alliances
potentially fighting each other that's
terrifying to me so I'm always worried
about war I always will be so long as
there are militaries and there probably
will be but so I'm split I don't know if
the same you know what I'm okay with
ending a show on I don't know right say
that's the difference between this show
and most other shows as long as you're
okay and in that way very okay all right
very good well for moral Daddy is check
him out on the Twitter although he's not
on the Twitter that much but he'll jump
on for you it's at Thaddeus Russell and
thanks for watching we'll do it again
next week
[Music]
you